ANNOUNCER: The
following content is
provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Then let's talk
about exciting physics, the Lamb
shift.
So we discussed the
Lamb shift last Friday,
and the Lamb shift is
really due to the fact
that, if you have
a atom consisting
of an electron, a Coulomb
field, and the proton,
this is not the
complete description.
The atom lives in a
vacuum, and the vacuum
is filled with
electromagnetic waves.
So what we have to include,
for an accurate description
of atomic level
structure, is the coupling
of the atomic system, of the
electron, to all of the modes
the electromagnetic field,
and this is radiation.
We will talk about the quantized
electromagnetic field later,
at this point I
could introduce you
to a simple model, fairly
accurate model of the Lamb
shift, by simply
assuming, and that's
what we did on Friday,
that we have fluctuating
electric fields, those
fluctuating electric fields
shake, accelerate, the
electron and the electron
performs some oscillatory motion
and this oscillatory motion
leads to an ever reaching
of the Coulomb potential.
And similarly what we
saw for the Darwin term,
this ever reaching of
the Coulomb potential
takes away this singularity
of the Coulomb potential
and therefore lowers the
binding energy of the electron.
So today I want to just say a
few more words about the result
we derived, and
then we have done
what happens to an electron in
a Coulomb field plus radiation.
The next thing is, then, to
discuss hyperfine structure.
So let me first make
one comment, when
we integrated over all modes of
the electromagnetic spectrum,
we needed an upper
cutoff, and a lower
cutoff due to logarithmic
singularities.
Eventually, an upper cutoff
is relativistic rest mass
of the electron we
have to cut off things.
I just want to say one more
word about the lower cutoff.
I suggested, as a cut
off, the orbital frequency
of the electron.
So the justification for that
is the following, the electron,
the free electron-- the free
electron, when it's driven,
has an amplitude which is 1
over the frequency squared.
So if you drive it
slower and slower,
it's amplitude
increases because it
has more time to go
in one direction.
So this divergence at
low frequency, of course,
happens only for
the free system.
When you have a bound system,
like a mnemonic oscillate,
and you drive it at lower
and lower frequency,
the response converges
to a constant
and not to 1 over high
frequency squared singularity.
So therefore, when we reach the
drive and the high frequencies
on the order of-- oscillatory
frequency of the bound system,
the behavior changes.
So when we mimic this with
an effect cutoff because what
you want to get rid of is a
singularity, but in reality,
of course, it should approach
a constant at low frequency,
and that is essentially the
physics of the AC and then
the DC Stark effect.
So that was a rational
for the cutoff
and let me just
annotate it here.
And let's say, for
a free particle
we had the situation that the
amplitude was proportional to 1
over the high frequency.
Whereas four bound
particle is, you
should approach a constant
for low frequencies.
And that's what we have
introduced with a cutoff.
OK.
So we have discussed
the Lamb shift,
but you've already discussed one
contribution to the Lamb shift.
So this was a contribution
that the Coulomb potential
is effectively smeared
out, and the result of this
is that there is a
weaker binding energy.
However, there is a second
contribution to the Lamb shift.
I've sometimes
seen sources where
this is discussed as the main
contribution to the Lamb shift,
but this is not correct.
This is only 3% off the total
and contributes 27 megahertz.
This is what is called
the vacuum polarization.
So if you have a-- the
proton positive charge
and you have the electron, and
they scatter off each other,
and we use this kind of
diagram to indicate that,
now that there is an
additional diagram which
has this bubble which is
this production of e minus
and e plus pairs.
And you can say that if an
electron and proton attract
each other and you create,
by virtual pair production--
because the vacuum
is alive, things
can happen in the
vacuum-- it will virutally
[INAUDIBLE] electron
positron pair that now you
create electron positron pairs,
which shield the Coulomb field.
And this is a
second contribution
in addition to the shaking
motion of the electron.
So I want you to just think
about it for 10 seconds
before I tell you the answer.
Does this vacuum polarization
strengthen or weaken
the binding energy?
Anybody want to
offer an opinion?
Whatever you say,
you can't be wrong
because there are to
aspects to the answers so.
Well then the actual
answer is you would say,
if you have charged--
if you create charges
between the electron
and the proton,
you have a shielding effect
and the shielding effect
should weaken the Coulomb field.
But the question is,
what do we regard
as the elementary charge, e,
in our Schrodinger equation.
And what we regard
as the charge, what
is measured in a Millikan
Droplet experiment,
is already the shielded charge.
So therefore, the fact
that vacuum polarization
exists means we always
measure the shielded charge,
but because vacuum polarization
happens at a finite distance,
the electron, in an s state,
can sort of penetrate the shield
and feel a somewhat
stronger Coulomb potential.
So therefore,
accounting for the fact
that we have these
virtual electron
positron pairs actually
means that the binding energy
is increased and the
vacuum polarization
has the opposite sign
as the dominant effect
we've mentioned earlier.
So the sum of e is, we observe
the shielded charge and vacuum
polarization implies that
the s electron can penetrate
the shield and sees
a higher charge.
So we normally observe
the shielded charge,
but the electron can
see the higher charge.
So therefore, that means, now,
that we have, not an upshift
in energy, but a downshift in
energy for-- which for the two
is one half state,
is 27 megahertz,
as I mentioned earlier.
Anyway, I'm not
really deriving it,
but I want to sort of uncover
certain myths, so the vacuum
polarization, number one, is
not dominant and number two,
has the opposite sign as
everybody would naively assume.
Questions?
I hope not because I don't
know anything more about that.
All right.
So we have dealt
with Lamb shift.
So is next now, in revealing
the atomic structure,
is we want to go beyond
the Coulomb field created
by a point charge.
And that means we want to
address the fact that we don't
have a point charge,
but we have a nucleolus.
And we are discussing, now,
effects of the nucleus, which
also go by the name
hyperfine structure.
So, just to summarize,
so far we have
treated, in pretty much
complete detail, what
happens for an atom which
consists of a point charge
and electrons.
But now we want
to bring in that,
what creates a Coulomb field,
the nucleolus, has structure.
And there are actually
four different ways
how the nucleolus has
structure and contributions
to observable effects
on the atomic structure
and atomic energy levels.
The most important one
is that the nucleus
has a magnetic moment
associated with the angular
momentum of the nucleus I.
The second contribution is, in
addition to magnetic moment,
there may be a
quadrupole moment.
And since those effects can
lead to a splitting-- this
is actually, usually,
called hyperfine structure,
but then there are
two more effects.
One is the nucleus
has finite mass,
and the nucleus has
a finite volume.
Both the mass and volume
effect lead to energy shifts.
But tiny energy shifts
are hard to measure
unless you have two
different shifts,
and therefore those effects
go as isotope shifts
because when you
have an atom which
comes in two
different isotopes you
find that, due to
those two effects,
the energy levels
are not the same.
So this goes by the
name of isotope shifts.
By far the most important
phenomenon is the first one.
The fact that if a nucleus
has angular momentum,
we have hyperfine structure,
and for the hydrogen atom
that means that the ground
state, the singlet S 1/2 state,
actually splits into two states
with total angular momentum
quantum number F.
So the relevance of
hyperfine splitting
is, it's actually
a huge relevance,
one is, you don't have a single
ground state of many atoms,
you have several ground states.
So the lowest electronic state
has several ground states,
has several hyperfine states,
due to angular momentum
selection, where
you can actually
talk to them individually, you
can prepare them individually,
and many of you who do
magnetic trapping know when
need magnetic trapping
you better prepare
the atom in a single
hyperfine state,
otherwise you are in trouble.
So you can prepare
individual states.
In the old days this was
done by optical pumping,
and you can use several
hyperfine states
to great advantage for
the manipulation of atoms.
For instance, if
you want to, you
can put atoms into
a hyperfine state
where they don't absorb
light, and then you
can have resonant light for the
other ones blast those away.
So you can play, sort of,
your tricks because you
have two states between which
you can juggle at the atoms.
Well, what else is relevance
of hyperfine structure?
OK if you have two levels,
F equals 1, F equals 0,
you can observe a transition.
And the famous 21
centimeter line
is used for astronomical
observations.
Hydrogen is the most abundant
element in the universe,
and how do you see
hydrogen out there.
Well it is due to hyperfine
transition, the 21 centimeter
line.
And finally, another aspect
why hyperfine structure
is relevant, where
people use it,
is for the determination
of nuclear properties.
How do you know what the
properties of nuclei are?
Well there are techniques
in nuclear physics,
but a lot, a lot about
the knowledge of nuclei
comes from atomic spectroscopy.
If you measure atomic energy
levels with high accuracy,
you figure out what the
properties of the nucleus is,
and one of the most outstanding
examples we will discuss later
on, and some of which is also
on your homework assignment,
is you can use atomic
spectroscopy of hydrogen
to contain the most
accurate measurement, how
big is the proton.
And the big surprise is that
there is, that there was,
a surprise that
people figured out
that, until now, even
in 2014, we do not fully
understand how big the
proton is but we'll
talk about that later.
So for the level of this-- the
level of this introduction,
we can use it for determination
of nuclear properties
and actually, you cannot only
determine properties of stable
nuclei, you can also determine
properties of unstable nuclei.
At various accelerators,
they have a facility
when, by, you know,
energy collisions
they create unstable nuclei.
Maybe helium six, helium
with four newtons, it exists.
And you can take helium
six, extract it, utilize it
and then you've have
a neutral helium
atom which looks like your
every days helium atom
but it has two more
neutrons in the nucleus.
And by performing
atomic spectroscopy,
you can figure out what
is the deformation, what
is the structure, of this--
I want to say alpha particle,
but it's an alpha particle
plus two neutrons.
So people have really learned
to do those atomic physics
measurements within
a few seconds
after the element
has been produced,
and such determined
nuclear properties even
of unstable nuclei.
OK.
So that's my introduction.
So we are now discussing
the most important effect
due to the hyperfine structure.
And this is the fact
that the nucleolus has
a magnetic moment, and
this magnetic moment
couples to the
magnetic field even
if you don't apply an
external magnetic field,
we talked about that
on Wednesday, there
is an internal
magnetic field created
by the electron with total
angular momentum change.
So this is, so to speak,
the Zeeman Hamiltonian
of the nucleus in the magnetic
field created by the electron.
And I will show you quickly
to, is a simple derivation,
what the result of that is.
But before I do that, I
also want to mention out--
mention that there is--
I want to point out
that there is an alternative.
Right now, I said we say
the nucleus experiences
the magnetic field
created by the electron.
But we can also take
the other approach,
the nucleus creates a
vector potential because
of its magnetic moment,
and the electron,
which goes around the
nucleus, is not only
feeling the Coulomb
potential but also
feeling a vector potential.
And of course, both
different perspectives,
whether the electron moves in
the magnetic field the nucleus,
or the nucleus experiences the
magnetic field of the electron,
both treatments have to agree.
I follow the more
standard treatment,
but the alternative treatment,
where the electron moves
in this electric and magnetic
potential of the nucleus,
is fully elaborated on
the atomic physics wiki.
So alternatively, electron
moves in the potential
of the nucleus, which is
the Coulomb potential,
we've discussed that,
but then there is also
vector potential created by the
magnetic moment of the nucleus.
So you simply assume this
is a potential created
with a nucleus,
and then you just
sort of Schrodinger's
equation and this approach
is carried out on the wiki.
However, since it's a
little bit more standard,
and there's an easy
semi-classical derivation,
let me now discuss this one.
Because what I
like about it is it
addresses one intuitive
quantity, namely the fact
that there is an
internal magnetic field.
We're not just using
the Schrodinger equation
for the whole
system, we are really
estimating what is the
magnetic field, which
the electron creates, at
the position of the nucleus.
So let's now do a
semi-classical derivation
of this internal magnetic field.
And I have to-- I will
immediately tell you,
this derivation
agrees quantitatively
with the fully
thermomechanical treatment.
So, as often as these
semi-classical derivations,
we have to separate two parts.
There are two ways how
the electron creates
a magnetic field at the nucleus.
One is due to it's
orbital motion,
the electron is a ring current
and creates a magnetic field,
but then the electron has
magnetic moment for-- due
to it's spin.
The spin part is simply the
potential of a magnetic dipole,
you will need to vector--
you will need to vector where
the magnetic dipole
moment of the electron
is proportional to it's
spin with a g factor.
However, and you can find
that in all textbooks
on classical
electrodynamics but, there
is one important term
which we have to add here,
which is also part
of classical E and M,
and this is the delta
function contribution.
You've probably seen it,
you find it in Jackson,
if you haven't the
model is that you
can assume that a
magnetic moment is created
by ring current,
and the ring current
has-- creates a
magnetic moment and you
have the dipole potentially
due to the magnetic moment.
However, if you
have a ring current,
there is-- you
can also ask, what
is the magnetic field
inside the current loop
and then eventually do
the transition where
you allow the current
loop to go to 0.
That's how you make a point
model of a magnetic dipole,
but what remains is, sorts
of-- as a delta function,
the location inside the loop.
I'm emphasizing it
because it will be,
eventually, the delta
function contribution,
which is important
for s electrons,
and therefore it is
this contribution
which is the dominant
effect in many situations.
OK.
So this is the magnetic
field created--
it's a classical expression,
but it's buried in [? quantum ?]
mechanics, the expression for
the magnetic field created
by the spin.
The second contribution is
the orbital contribution,
and for that semi-classical,
we just use Biot-Savat.
So Biot-Savat is usually
the 3-Dimensional integral
over the current density.
The volume integral,
or you can rewrite it
as the current I, d, r
cross r, over r cubed.
And eventually, if you now
put in the electron charge
distribution, velocity
course r, well,
velocity cross r means we
get, and that's what we want,
the orbital angular momentum.
The 1 over r cubed
term means we have
to calculate an expectation
value over the wave
function which,
is 1 over r cubed.
And the prefactor
leads us-- it's
nothing else than two
times the Bohr magenton.
So, with those two terms, we can
now obtain our final expression
for the total magnetic
field generated
by the electron at the origin.
And for that I use
the g factor of two
as it comes out of Dirac theory.
So now we have the
total magnetic field.
We had this contribution
L over r cubed.
If you inspect the dipole
potential of the spin
it has a contribution
S over r cubed,
then it is the
second contribution
to the dipole potential.
And finally, most importantly
for the following discussion,
the delta function contribution
which I discussed earlier.
If you have an s state,
these first terms
are 0 for L equals 0 because
these are, sort of, terms which
have dipole potential
where positive and negative
contributions cancel out when
you do a spherical average,
and the s electron performs
a spherical average.
So it is 0 for L equals 0
due to the spherical average.
Whereas the second part, it
would be 0 for L non-equals
to 0 because the probability
for a non-s electron
to be at the nucleus is 0.
So pretty much this
describes that.
So this describes a
hyperfine structure.
Well, it describes the magnetic
field created by the electron,
and now we have to do
the usual projection
in the following way.
That the hyperfine structure
is that Zeeman Hamiltonian
of the internal magnetic
field with a magnetic moment
of the nucleus, and the
magnetic moment of the nucleus
is proportional to the angular
momentum of the nucleus.
Sort of this argument that even
if it were not proportional,
it would rapidly precess
and eventually project it,
and the only direction
which survives
is the direction of
the angular momentum.
And similarly, you can--
the magnetic field,
you have a contribution
of S and L,
but S and L rapidly precess
around the result and angular
momentum, J, and
therefore, as a result,
the internal magnetic
field must be,
can only be, parallel to
the angular momentum chain.
If you do a fully
[? quantum ?] treatment,
it comes out immediately.
But if you do it
semi-classically, you calculate
a magnetic field, you sort of
have to fall in this argument
that you always project on
the axis of angular momentum
and that means that the
hyperfine interaction will
be the Hamiltonian for
it, or the operator,
will be the dot product of
I dot J. For fine structure,
we had L dot S, for hyperfine
structure, we had L dot J,
this is always how we couple
angular momentum with a dot
product.
The hyperfine constant
cause by the letter
a, and since historically a is
measured in frequency units,
in Hertz, I have to put
in h, Planck's quantum.
No it's not h bar.
For historical reasons, it's h.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are I and
J dimensionless,
or will they carry
units in h bar?
PROFESSOR: Here they
are dimensionless,
thanks for the question, because
each is in frequency units,
it's in Hertz, and if
you multiple with h
you have an energy.
So therefore, I and J
measure the angular momentum
in unit of h bar.
So it's not in that sense, it's
a normalized angular momentum
operator.
The quantum numbers of I and
J are not 1/2, or 1h bar,
it's just 1/2 or 1.
Other questions?
OK.
I can now take this expression
with, you know, L and S
and S.r and evaluate
further, but I
feel I'm not
providing any insight
and you can read
about it on the wiki.
So for a non-s state, how
to simplify this expression
and get the final textbook
result, I defer to the wiki.
I want to discuss the most
important part, namely for s v
electrons because hydrogen,
all the alkaloids,
have an s ground state.
So, in that case, all we have to
consider is the delta function
part and if we project
the magnetic field
onto the angular
momentum axis, we
get the probability of the s
electron to be at the origin.
And therefore, for s states,
the hyperfine constant
is-- oh, I forgot one thing.
We have to parametrize the
magnetic moment of the nucleus,
and that is done by using
a nuclear magnetron.
It's the same as a
Bhor magneton, where
you have replaced the electron
mass by the proton mass,
and you have the
nuclear g factor.
Just as a reminder, the g
factor of the proton is 5.6,
the g factor of the
neutron is minus 3.8.
So the g factor has nothing
to do, not even close,
to the factor of 2, which we
obtained in the Dirac equation
for the electron.
That just shows that the
nucleons, protons and neutrons,
are more complicated.
Well, they have
quarks inside, they
have a complicated
internal structure.
OK.
So therefore the hyperfine
constant involves,
now, the g factor
of the nucleus,
the product of the
nuclear magnetron,
with a Bohr magneton,
and for hydrogen.
This gives the famous
result of 1420 megahertz.
So this is hydrogen, and this
h is now the Hamiltonian.
So the hyperfine coupling
Hamiltonian, which has I
dot J, by using the expression
for the total angular momentum
I plus J and then we square it.
When you evaluate
this square you get,
on the right hand side,
an expression for I dot J.
So I dot J is nothing
else than 1/2.
F squared, minus I
squared, minus J squared.
And therefore, for hydrogen,
where I, J and S are all 1/2,
the proton has been
1/2, the electron
has been 1/2, that's it.
You have only two values of
the result and total angular
momentum, 1/2 and 1/2
can add up to 1 or 0.
And now the hyperfine
splitting is into an F equals 1
and F equals 0 state.
And one thing to remember is,
if you inspect the above formula
with the [? quantum ?]
numbers you find immediately
that, compared to
the degenerate line,
without hyperfine
splitting, this--
so what comes out of
the Dirac equation,
the splitting is the
fight-- is 1/4 and 3/4
of the hyperfine constant.
Since F equals 1 has a
multiplicity of 3, 2 and F
quantum numbers,
plus minus 1 and 0,
the rule is that the center
of mass of this level
does not change due to
hyperfine splitting.
So the center of mass
of hyperfine states
is not changing.
So we introduce a
level splitting,
but no overall shift.
Any questions about magnetic
hyperfine structure?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would you explain
again the center of mass
is not changing.
Is this just for hydrogen?
Or is this a general rule?
PROFESSOR: No, this
is a general property,
and you could actually
show that when you evaluate
the product of I dot
J. So, the product of I
dot J means that for arbitrary
I and arbitrary J, if you
calculate the hyperfine
structure, the center of mass
is the same.
OK.
I've not done any
experiment in my life
where higher order
moments became important,
but I want to teach you about
it because the discussion
about whether those
higher moments exist
or not is really an interesting
discussion about what
is allowed by symmetry
and what's not.
So I'm bringing in
a higher moments,
not so much because you need
it to understand the level
structure of your
favourite atom,
but because it teaches us a
really nice piece of physics.
So let me now discuss higher
order moments and the leading
one is the electric
quadripole moment.
So I want to raise, in
general, the question,
what further moments
can a nucleus have.
What we have discussed so far
is the magnetic moment, mu.
So beyond mu, what further
electric or magnetic moments
can a nucleus have?
Well, it's a question
about symmetry
and if you look at the
parity of multiples,
if you have an electric
multiple-- well,
you know if you have a dipole,
plus minus, you invert it,
the dipole becomes
minus the dipole.
So for L equals 1, it
is minus 1, L is 1,
but in general
the it is minus L.
If you have a quadripole, you
invert your coordinate system.
It's L equals 2, plus
plus, minus minus,
you invert it nothing changes.
So these I've shown you,
for dipole and quadripole,
that this formula is correct.
So an electric multiple
has this parity,
and for, magnetic
keys-- now, you
know, magnetic we have axial
vectors versus polar vectors,
there's always an extra
factor of minus 1.
So therefore if you go magnetic,
magnetic multiples with L
have a parity of minus L plus 1.
So this really restricts
what multiples are possible.
Instead of giving you
a general discussion,
let me just look at the
very important keys.
Whether a magnet with a nucleus
can have a electric dipole
moment, and you will immediately
see what it needs to-- and then
I give you a general result.
So let's assume a nucleus
has angular momentum I,
and there is a magnetic
moment, mu associated with it.
So the general result is
that odd electric and even
magnetic multiple moments
would violate not just one,
but two symmetries, would
violate parity and time
reversal symmetry.
So the argument goes as follows.
Let us assume this is
the magnetic moment, mu
or the angular momentum
I, it's a vector.
And now we are asking,
is it possible to have
a vector of the dipole moment.
And dipole moment, you
should just think about it
as a plus minus
charge, separated.
We can now do the parity
operation and the time reversal
operation.
If you do the time
reversal operation,
the current, which
generates a magnetic moment
if you want to think
about it in this picture,
goes the other way.
So mu flips but nothing
moves, of course,
for an electric dipole
moment, so reversing time
is not changing anything.
So in other words,
time reversal symmetry
transforms parallel mu and d
into anti-parallel mu and d.
And similar, parity
is not changing mu
but it is changing d.
So in both cases, would parity,
or time reversal symmetry,
if you had mu-d, a
scalar product of mu
and d which would be
known 0, then both P or P
would change the sign.
But that would mean that two
kinds of particles would exist,
one where the sign is positive,
one where the sign is negative.
But we have assumed that we have
1 nucleus and only 1 nucleus
of this kind, so we cannot
have one nucleus which has
the properties of
having, simultaneously,
a magnetic and
electric dipole moment.
So therefore, we conclude
that mu times d has to be 0.
And if you generalize
this argument,
we have ruled out that
there is an electric dipole
moment, an odd electric moment.
The first, the lowest,
possible electric moment
is the quadripole moment, so the
leading electric moment is not
L equals 2, L equals
2, it's not L equals 1,
the dipole, it's L
equals 2 the quadripole.
And of course if you
generalize the argument,
L equals 4, L equals
6, would be possible
but those effects
would be very small.
Questions so far?
OK.
So we've talked about parity and
time reversal symmetry, which
restricts what kind of magnetic
and electric dipole moments
particles may have.
And maybe in this
context, I should just
mention that John Doyle, Jerry
Gabrielse, and Dave Demille
at Harvard and Yale, they just
published the most accurate
result for the electric
dipole moment of the electron.
They found a bound, which was
more than an order of magnitude
lower than the best
upper bound before
and this has really
made headlines.
So to measure, accurately,
that the electric dipole
moment vanishes, in this
case of the electron,
but other people do
it also for neutrons,
is testing fundamental
symmetries.
In particular, it
tests whether nature
is time reversal invariant.
And the reason why,
until now, everybody
has found that the results
are compatible with 0
is pretty much based on the
argument I just gave you.
OK so we have discussed
those fundamental symmetries,
but now I want to discuss
something else related to it.
So let's assume
you have a nucleus,
and I want to discuss with
you, is a minimum requirement
for the nucleus for the
angular momentum of the nucleus
in order to have
a magnetic dipole,
or to have an
electric quadripole.
So let's formulate it
as a quicker question.
So here let's assume a is--
it's possible for any nucleus
no matter what the
angular momentum is.
Here, we put in 1/2,
or larger than 1,
and for the electric quadripole
we have the same choices.
So you should decide
if I tell you,
a nucleolus has a
magnetic dipole.
Does that imply that
there is a minimum amount
of angular momentum
of the nucleus there?
And then repeat
the same question
for the electric quadripole.
So please tell me your opinion.
So right now, what is
a minimum requirement
for I, for magnetic dipole,
and if yes, what is it?
Three, two, one.
Stop.
OK, so-- and let's
immediately consider
the electric quadripole moment.
So this was a majority opinion.
I gave this answer for
both of them together.
So the question is, what
is the minimum requirement
for a nucleus to have an
electric quadripole moment.
OK, stop.
Display.
No requirement.
OK.
So the majority
onset was a here.
So let me to discuss it,
and I know some of you
will have-- I always get into
heated discussions with it.
I actually just had a few
minute discussion with one
of my colleagues about
it, who at least wanted
to look at it from a different
perspective than I did.
So let me give you
the short answer
and we can go from there.
In order to the magnetic dipole
you have to take an object,
turn it around, and
figure out that there's
a different energy.
So therefore, unless
you have an object,
which is has two orientations,
you cannot figure out if it has
a magnetic dipole or not.
If you're in a state without
angular momentum, I equals 0,
there is no
distinguishable states.
You cannot orient a 0 angular
momentum object in space.
So therefore you
can never figure out
that there's a magnetic
moment, and now I'll
make a bold statement,
and this means
there is no magnetic moment.
So therefore, you
need this because you
need a minimum number
of true orientations.
OK.
Now an electric quadripole
means that the charge density
is like ellipse.
It has--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, 1/2, sorry.
Thank you.
So I should get larger
than 1/2 because we
need a minimum of two
possible orientations.
Now my question for you is, you
think something is elliptical
but how many different
orientations do
you need to figure out that it
is elliptical and not round.
If I equal 0, you can only look
at it, you can't rotate it,
so will you never find any
energies [? breathing. ?]
It's just there and you cannot
say where it's round or whether
it has a quadripole
or deformation.
If I is equal to 1/2, you can
take it and flip it around
but can you tell from
that that it's an ellipse.
No because if you turn an
ellipse around nothing changes.
So it could be,
as well, a sphere.
You can only figure
out that it's
an ellipse if you have
an intermediate rotation,
let's say, by 90 degrees.
So in order to assess that
something is elliptical,
you have to at least resolve
three positions, three angles,
and three angles require that
you have to three sublevels
and this requires that I is
larger, or equal, than one.
Sorry.
Then one goes-- OK.
I'm want to give you a
formal argument using
this spherical
tensor, but I guess
someone you are waiting
for something simpler.
So.
I mean who wants to know
the answer of the question,
but what happens if
it has a deformation.
Does it just mean
we can't measure it,
but it has a deformation?
Let me explain that.
So if I have a pencil and
the pencil has zero angular
momentum, I can't
really figure out
that it's an elongated object,
because all I measure is
a symmetric wave function.
It's completely
spherically symmetric.
The only way to figure
out that it's a pencil
is I have to localize
it, that I can
see that it's
pointing somewhere.
But to localize
an object in space
is actually an
angular wave packet.
It's not isotropic.
It points somewhere.
And an angular wave
packet is a superposition
of states of different
angular momenta.
So therefore, without assuming
that there is a state with
angular momentum, I
cannot orient this pencil.
OK.
I know you would all agree that
even if this pencil is cooled
to the ground state with
zero angular momentum,
it is a pencil.
But what you're using
here is now your knowledge
that this object has higher
angular momentum states.
And those higher
angular momentum
states have nothing to do with
the structure or the appearance
of this object of
being a pencil.
So you sort of know that
in addition to the i
equals 0 state, there are i
equals 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 states,
and the pencil looks the same.
But if you have a
nucleus, an i equals
0 state requires a certain
configuration of quarks.
And you cannot create an i
equals 2, and i equals 4,
higher states without messing
around with the internal
structure.
So with a nucleus, all you
have is an i equals 0 state.
And to say that this i equals
0 state has a quadrupolar
deformation doesn't
make any sense.
If you would know that this
nuclear state could be rotated
without changing its internal
structure, then you would say,
yes, it has a quadrupole
moment, I just can't see it.
But usually, you cannot
make this assumption.
If all you have is an i
equals 0 ground state,
and the i equals 2 state
is very, very different,
because the quarks are
spinning around each other
in a different way,
you have to see,
i equals 0 is
completely spherical.
It doesn't couple to
anything externally.
And therefore, it has
no moments whatsoever.
So that's the story.
A lot of people get
confused, because they
think an object can have a
deformation without rotating.
But you need the
rotation to resolve it.
If you cannot create
an angular wave packet,
which is a superposition
state of angular momenta,
you can never figure out
that there is a deformation.
And quantum mechanically, if you
cannot figure out that there is
a deformation, there
is no deformation,
because you can only use, in the
language of quantum mechanics,
where you have at least the
possibility to measure it.
Questions about that?
OK.
I think that makes it now--
let me now kind of just
give you a formal.
A formal derivation.
But I agree.
I mean, the formal
derivation, I'm
just throwing a few equations
at you, and say, that's it
and everything
follows from that.
But I provided the
insight for you.
Formally, you can define
the quadrupole moment
by the expectation operator.
You take the nucleus
with maximum MI.
And now you calculate
the expectation value
of this operator.
This is, of course, motivated
by just electrostatics.
If you take an expansion of the
classical electrostatic energy
into multi-poles, you find
the quadrupole configuration
to be related to a
quadripole moment.
Quadrupole moments couple to the
derivative of electric fields.
And then in this purely
classical description,
you have this
term, where beta is
the angle between two
symmetry axis, namely,
between the symmetry axis of
the electric field gradient
and the quadrupole tensor-- just
the classic quadrupole tensor
as it comes out of Jackson.
Yes.
You can see the quantum
mechanical definition
of the quadrupole moment,
or more generally.
So this is quadrupole moment.
If you have a moment
with l, the operator,
which tells you whether you
have a non-vanishing moment,
a non-vanishing
deformation, is actually
a spherical tensor, Tlm.
And what you see above
is a spherical tensor,
T20-- l equals 2, m equals 0.
And those spherical tensors
are defined by the fact
that they transform as
spherical harmonics.
And now you sort of
realize what it means.
If you want a magnetic or
electric moment with l,
the operator for the
moment transforms
like angular momentum l.
And now you realize that
you have the triangle rule.
If you want a matrix element
where I and l overlap with I,
you want to make sure
that I, l, and I couple.
And you have a triangle rule.
So therefore, if you
want a magnetic moment,
or electric moment, of l, and
you evaluate this expectation
value, well, at least
the triangle rules
can only be justified like this.
Or in other words, you can
only get a non-vanishing moment
if l is smaller than 2I.
And this is what we discussed
in the clicker question
for the two cases of l
equals 1 and l equals 2.
So ultimately, it's
a selection rule
which is related to
the triangle rule
for the addition
of angular momenta.
But I like much
better the argument,
how many orientations
do you need
to find out that
something is elliptical?
It's formalized here.
All right.
Let's just spend one more minute
on the quadrupolar structure.
So based on the expansion of
the electrostatic energy, what
determines the
quadrupolar structure
is this cosine angle,
which is the angle
between the axis of the
nucleus and the axis
of an electric field gradient.
And that means it is the angle.
It's a cosine of
the angle between J,
the outer environment, and
I, the axis of the nucleus.
So therefore, when we would
derive-- I'm not deriving it,
but if we would derive an
expression for quadrupolar
structure, the
quadrupolar structure
would be proportional
to a quantity C, which
is nothing else than the
dot product of I and J.
And at least in my notes now,
I and J have units of h bar.
So I'm dividing it out here.
And as you know, I,
dot, J can be expressed
by quantum numbers F, F
plus 1, minus I, I plus 1,
minus J, J plus 1.
So therefore, the
quadrupolar energies-- E2,
El equals 2-- involve
the classical expression
at cosine square.
So therefore, you would expect
there is a quadrupole constant.
And then it is cosine square.
But well, usually,
quantum mechanic
even, we have the
square of a quantity,
we have to write it as
quantity times quantity plus 1.
So this is the
quadrupolar structure.
And to remind you,
we just discussed
that for the hydrogen atom, the
magnetic hyperfine structure
had invoiced the same product of
I, dot, J, but in a linear way.
So the reason why I'm not
discussing quadrupolar
structure in more
detail is usually
the hyperfine
structure associated
with quadrupole moments
is much, much smaller
than the hyperfine
structure associated
with magnetic moment,
typically by a factor of 100.
The only exceptions
are molecules,
because molecules
can have-- because
of molecular binding
mechanisms-- a much, much
larger electric field gradient.
So therefore, in molecules,
quadrupolar structure
is more important than in atoms.
Questions about that?
With that, we have
discussed the two effects
of hyperfine structure due to
magnetic moment of the nucleus.
And we also discussed further
deformations of the nucleus,
in particular, the
quadrupolar deformation.
Let me now use the
last 10 minutes
to quickly discuss with
you isotope effects.
And I know that many people
here know about isotope effects,
because if you lock your
laser to a lithium cell
or to a rubidium cell, you find
lithium-6 and lithium-7 peaks.
And in rubidium,
rubidium-85 and rubidium-87.
So there are two peaks which
are spectrally very, very
well resolved.
And now I tell you what causes
the splitting between the lines
of rubidium-85 and rubidium-87.
Well, the first effect
is really trivial.
It's the mass effect.
And I have to remind
you that the Rydberg
formula for a single
electron energy level
contains the reduced mass.
In other words,
the energy levels
are the energy
levels-- if you assume
that the mass of the nucleus is
infinite, that means you just
take for the electron mass
in the Rydberg constant
the electron mass.
But in general, you have
to take the reduced mass--
the big M is the nucleus.
And small m is the electron.
The simplest case is if you set
the nuclear mass to infinity.
Then you simply have the Rydberg
constant with the electron
mass.
So in the limit that
the nuclear mass is
much larger than
the electron mass,
this correction factor is 1
minus little m over big M.
So therefore, the correction
factor is on the order of 10
to the 4 or 10 to the 5.
Visible frequencies are on
the order of 10 to the 14.
So 10 to the minus 4 or
10 to the minus 5 of it
is between 1 and 10 gigahertz.
So this is the scale
for mass corrections
due to the isotope effect.
What is the sine of
the isotope effect?
Does the fact that the
nucleus has a finite mass--
does that mean that the
binding energy of the electron
is smaller or larger?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it would be larger.
PROFESSOR: The absolute
value of the binding energy--
look at your signs.
I would say it in the following.
Let's start out with
an infinite nucleus,
and only the electron is moving.
But now we make the
nucleus lighter.
And that means the
nucleus also has to move,
because it's a two-body problem.
And there is additional
kinetic energy,
additional kinetic
energy of the nucleus.
And kinetic energy is positive
and weakens the binding energy
of the total system.
So therefore, the fact that the
effective mass correction means
the lighter the nucleus
is, the more kinetic energy
has to be added to the system
for the nuclear motion,
and the more the binding
energy is weakened.
The most dramatic example
is not the hydrogen atom.
It is positronium, where your
nucleus is not a nucleus,
it's a positively charged
electron to the positronium.
And in this situation,
you have an effective mass
which is only 1/2 of
the electron mass.
And the 1s-2s transition, which
is Lyman alpha for hydrogen,
is now not even
in the vacuum UV,
it just happens at
ordinary UV transitions.
And that means now
the 1s-2s energy
is smaller by a factor of 2.
That really means the binding
energy between an electron
and a positron is only
50% of the binding energy
of an electron in
the hydrogen atom.
OK.
That's all I want to say
about the mass effect.
Let's now talk about
the volume effect.
So if you would look at
the charge distribution
in a nucleus as a function of
r, if we go from one isotope
to a heavier isotope
with more neutrons,
the nuclear radius
becomes larger
and the charge becomes
more spread out.
So if I plot now the
electrostatic potential,
the electrostatic potential
is, of course, the Coulomb
potential, 1 over r, until we
enter the charge distribution.
And then, as you know from
electrostatics, it continues.
This is 1 over r.
And then it's flattened off.
It continues quadratically
for the heavier-- oops,
I wanted to change color.
For the heavier nucleus,
it is like this,
and for the lighter
nucleus, it is like this.
So in other words, the
finite size of the nucleus
is cutting off the
Coulomb potential
where it is strongest.
And this happens the
earlier, the larger,
or the heavier the nucleus is.
So therefore, what you
obtain is you obtain,
in perturbation
theory, a level shift.
Since it only affects
the electron when
it's very close to the
origin, this level shift
is, as other effects we
have discussed today,
proportional to the
probability of the electron
to be at the center.
This is only s
electrons are effected.
What is the effect
in terms of energy?
Well, it's clear the Coulomb
potential is weakened.
Therefore, this effect,
the volume effect weakens,
decreases the binding
energy of the electron.
So we have two effects now-- we
have the volume effect, which
is the stronger the bigger and
the heavier the nucleus is.
So it's largest
for heavy nuclei.
And the mass effect, or
the effective mass effect,
is of course largest
for the lightest nuclei,
with the extreme
example of positronium.
Any questions?
Well, we have five minutes left.
But Cody.
AUDIENCE: What
sort of scales are
associated with
the volume effect?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: What sort
of energy scales
are associated with the volume
effect? [INAUDIBLE] comparable?
PROFESSOR: What energy is--
no, it's actually-- wait.
Let's estimate it.
You're working with rubidium.
What is your isotope shift in
rubidium between 85 and 87?
AUDIENCE: I actually don't know.
PROFESSOR: Isn't
it 170, 90-- no,
I'm getting confused
now with [INAUDIBLE].
So many people
work with rubidium.
What is the difference
in transition frequency
between rubidium-85 and -87?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's much
more than gigahertz.
You really have to
tune your laser.
I think if you look
at the wave per cell,
you will never accidentally
see a rubidium-85 line.
I just don't recall the number.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] together,
you can see both of them.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And for the mass
effect, we said it's
sort of-- then they
would be comparable.
The mass effect is
easy to estimate,
because the mass correction
is one part in a few thousand.
So that would mean on the order
of 10 to the 10 gigahertz.
So the volume effect--
it really depends.
It's tiny for light elements.
Rubidium is already heavy.
So right now I would
say they are comparable.
But since it's of
interest, I will give you
more accurate
numbers on Wednesday.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Could you explain the
graph of the previous page,
how the lines are joined off?
PROFESSOR: The potential?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So what happens is-- so
if we're being cryptic,
this is the charge distribution.
And what I'm doing now is
I'm solving Laplace equation.
I'm solving Laplace
equation and integrating
from r equals infinity.
And as long as I'm
outside the charge radius,
I get the 1 over r
Coulomb potential.
But the moment I heat the
surface of the nucleus,
I continue to indicate
Laplace equation.
But what is now inside is a
smaller and smaller charge.
I can also say I use
a form of Gauss's law.
So I'm therefore not
continuing on the 1 over r.
And if you look at
Jackson, or if you
look at maybe a PSET you have
solved, the 1 over r potential
becomes now a parabola.
And so what I wanted to
sort of indicate here
is once you heat the
surface of the nucleus,
you're not continuing on
the 1 over r trajectory.
You have in a wave which
is continuous and has
a continuous deriviative--
you have to fit in a parabola.
And for the heavier
nucleus, this
leads us to this potential.
As for the lighter nucleus,
the potential is deeper.
And that explains why the
binding energy for heavier
nuclei is smaller than
for lighter nuclei.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So for the
other orbitals, is it
exactly zero or
[? near to ?] zero?
PROFESSOR: OK.
For the other orbitals,
what we have to do
is-- and actually, you
have a homework assignment
to do it for hydrogen
and the proton.
You take the difference
between the actual potential
and the Coulomb potential.
So you take the difference.
And the difference is
your perturbation operator
for the finite size
of the nucleus.
And now you take this
perturbation operator
between your wave function
and calculate the lowest order
of the expectation value.
For the s electron,
you can immediately
factor out the probability
for the electronic s equals 0.
But s-- we discussed, if you
have orbital angular momentum,
let me just scribble
it down here,
the wave function is
proportional to r to the l.
So therefore, you
have actually an r
to the l-- the wave function is
exactly 0 only at r equals 0.
And then it slowly grows.
So therefore, given the
finite size of the nucleus,
you will get a tiny, an
absolutely tiny effect
if you integrate a wave
function, r to the l,
over your perturbation operator.
So it's not mathematically zero.
But for all practical
purposes, it vanishes.
Nancy.
AUDIENCE: For the different
nuclei-- for example,
in rubidium-- is mass and
volume affecting anything?
Or is [INAUDIBLE] structure also
important in these isotopes?
Because the nuclear structure
would be different [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
When we talk isotope
effects, I was
talking about the isotope
effects of mass and volume.
But different isotopes
will, in general,
have different magnetic moments
or different quadrupolar
deformations.
So what I discussed about
hyperfine structure also
applies to isotopes.
I only separated it,
because usually when
you don't have isotopes, you
don't talk about, like, sodium.
Who has ever talked about
the mass shift or volume
effect in sodium?
Usually you don't,
because sodium
has 100% natural
abundance in sodium-23.
So therefore, the
hyperfine effects,
they lead to
observable splittings
even if you have
only one isotope.
But in general, yes,
different isotopes
differ in all four effects-- the
mass effect, the volume effect,
the deformation effect, and
the magnetic moment effect.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] mass and
volume effects are used more
than [INAUDIBLE] splitting?
Because I find there
is a different rate
for different isotopes.
Like, in the starting
of the lecture,
you were talking about
adding two positrons
to the alpha particles.
That would change [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah,
this would change.
But you can separate
those effects,
because I mentioned that
in hyperfine structure,
the center of mass of the
energy levels is the same.
So if you see a splitting
but take the center of mass,
then the center
of mass will only
depend on volume
and mass effects.
OK.
Let's continue on Wednesday.